So hey everyone my name is Phoomparin Mano and I'm 16 years old developer from Thailand
And this is for the love of web assembly. Hope you enjoy it
First of all
Javascript is a big ecosystem, and this is what makes us great
As you can see there is react. There's Redux and graph QL and a bunch of other libraries and this makes our
Ecosystems be together and we can create any applications
We want just like the animals in the forest
Now
There are sometimes when JavaScript alone might not cut it for example when you have performance problems
You need more performance you need more computation power
maybe you need to figure out a face of someone and sometimes javascript might not be enough
Sometimes you just need to get really low level and just flip some bits
And this is what our friends come in with assembly
And this is like a tale of two worlds we have the JavaScript world which is the world of
simplicity, elegance and the world of web assembly which is a world of performance and
Once we combine these two worlds we can open a portal and make really great apps
Now
In webassembly it is a binary format, which you can use any language you want but for now I'll pick rust
The reason I pick rust is we call first is really modern you
Can use Map reduce, you can use
many a lot a libraries which can makes your life really easy and
Next Rust is like my mom my mom loves to school at me, but she's has good intentions
So when you write really bad code Rust will scream at you the compiler will not let you compile
Until you make your code good
At last it is really fast
Rust done a lot of shaking at compile time so it can
it can compile combine your code and
It makes everything really fast, and it can use a lot of LLVM optimizations
Now I
Know a lot of you might wonder
How hard it is to use it because it is from I know another world another language
But the good news is is really easy
First you have to import your module
Which you can import like another JavaScript module and the webpack loader will handle the rest for you
you can just
Await the module, and then you can call it like this from the JavaScript function as usual
Now how do you export your functions the good new is you can write your JavaScript directly in Rust
so you can do `console.log` from Rust you can do `module.exports` from Rust and
anything really you can modify the DOM, you can modify the canvas
and it will call out to JavaScript just for you and
This is a great part, so let's do some demo. Shall we?
Okay, so here's my commit history and you all can do this project at Phoomparin /react-rust
and
This is a starter kit so any of you can go and download it right away
Okay, so here's some knock-knock jokes
When I hit reply it will go call out to rust and fast and fast time replies for me. Here we go.
Oh, that wasn't what I expected
Okay
so
So the JavaScript code call out to Rust and it gives us some replies. Let's check the code and
As you can see you can just write react like you would as usual
But the good part is
You can simply import your web assembly functions and use it in your Redux reducer
So here I just make Redux, akka
listens for the actions, and then it will call out to
webassembly
Okay
So really this is our. I have to say
so thank you everyone for listening and
Have a great time. Thank you